[Music]
os
login is a compute engine service that
provides an easy way to manage user
permissions for accessing instances
via ssh using compute engine iim roles
however having multiple roles on
different resource levels
can make it confusing to figure out
access issues
let's take a look at how to investigate
ssh access issues with os login
and the iam policy troubleshooter first
let's review a few different roles for
users to use os login
compute.os admin login allows the user
to ssh
into the instance as an administrator
while compute.os login
allows them to ssh in as a regular user
the iim.service account user role
allows a user to run operations as a
service account
these roles can be granted at the
project level so they can apply to
resources inside that project
they can also be granted at a more
granular level such as an instance
or a service account directly let's walk
through an example
we'll start by trying to ssh into my
instance 1.
on the instances details page we can see
the service account for this instance
at the top of the page the ssh button
will let us connect to the instance
so let's go ahead and click it
looks like everything is working well
now let's try the same thing with my
instance 2.
we'll head over to the instance details
page from the main menu
this instance is also running the same
service account but
when we scroll up to the ssh option it's
grayed out
that's strange let's try it from the
command line instead
by using the cloud shell terminal and
running gcloud
compute ssh we get a permission denied
error which explains why the ssh button
was grayed out
but without any other details how can we
figure out why we don't have permission
let's evaluate the permissions required
in the policy troubleshooter
we can evaluate multiple permissions on
multiple resources at the same time
so that we can compare the results of
each let's check for the
compute.instances.os login permission
on my instance 1 and by instance 2. this
permission
comes from the roles that we mentioned
earlier we'll add our user as the
principal
and add the full resource name and
permission
also since these instances are running
as a service account
we can check for the
iam.serviceaccounts.act as permission
on the actual service account the
permission is part of the service
account user role
the policy troubleshooter shows us
details on the permissions for our users
we can change between our views by using
the drop down here
the first view shows us that os login is
granted to my instance 1
and we can see the specific details here
on the right
when we switch the view over to my
instance 2 we can see that our user
doesn't have the same permissions
since the user doesn't have the right
permissions they can't connect through
ssh
let's add our user by going to the
compute engine page from here we can
select the instance
and grant our user the compute.os login
role
now that we can see the user has the
role let's try connecting through ssh
again
once that's done we can see that the
user is now able to ssh in
another option would be to grant the
user compute.os login at the project
level which would allow them to use os
login for all
instances in the project keep in mind
the security best practice of least
privilege
and set your permissions accordingly
take a look at the documentation to read
more about policy troubleshooter